In den Zentren der meisten Galaxien befinden
sich supermassereiche Schwarze Löcher.
Doch die Sensation: In viel viele mehr Galaxien
als gedacht, befinden sich sogar zwei supermassereiche
Schwarze Löcher.
Und ein Forschungsteam hat jetzt den Todestanz
nämlich das Spätstadium der Todesspirale,
kurz vor ihrer Verschmelzung dieser Schwarzen
Löcher beobachtet.
Die spektakulären Aufnahmen dazu und alle
wichtigen Facts bekommt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich spannende
Wissenschaftsvideos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Knapp 500 Galaxien hat das Forschungsteam
systematisch untersucht - alle im Umkreis
von 330 Millionen Lichtjahren.
Dabei waren die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
auf der Spur nach supermassereichen Schwarzen
Löchern im Zentrum der Galaxien kurz vor
der Verschmelzung.
Bei ihrer Untersuchung nutzten sie das Swift-Röntgenteleskop,
um aktive Galaxienkerne zu detektieren.
Wenn dies gelang, nutzten sie die Datenbanken
vom Keck-Teleskop auf Hawaii und dem Hubble-Weltraumteleskop,
um sich die Aufnahmen genauer anzusehen.
Seit einiger Zeit ist bekannt, dass viele
Galaxien nicht nur eines, sondern direkt zwei
supermassereiche Schwarze Löcher in ihrem
Zentrum aufweisen.
Nach der Analyse des Forschungsteams war dies
bei 17 Prozent der aktiven Galaxien der Fall:
Ein Pärchen, bestehend aus zwei Schwarzen
Löchern, umkreiste sich gegenseitig.
Viel viel mehr als eigentlich gedacht.
Denn diese letzte Phase der Annäherung sei
extrem kurz und so wohl nur bei etwa einem
Prozent der aktiven Galaxien zu beobachten,
so zumindest die bisherige Annahme.
Aber es ist ganz anders.
Und aktuelle Simulation zeigen tatsächlich,
dass Schwarze Löcher fünfmal länger in
Entfernungen von 10.000 bis 30.000 Lichtjahren
verweilen, als wenn sie nur noch weniger als
10.000 Lichtjahre voneinander entfernt sind.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Michael
Koss aus Zürich: “Es war ziemlich beeindruckend,
diese verschmelzenden Galaxienkerne mit ihren
gigantischen Schwarzen Löchern so nah beieinander
zu sehen“.
Besonders spektakuläre Bilder zeigen sogar
das Spätstadium der Schwarzen Löcher, eben
kurz vor ihrer Verschmelzung.
Eine Art “Todestanz”, wie es die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler bildlich beschreiben.
Sie konnten zudem beobachten, dass die gigantischen
Schwarzen Löcher noch einmal rasant anwachsen,
kurz bevor sie kollidieren.
Und eben auch dieses extreme Wachstum in der
Endphase überraschte die Experten und Expertinnen.
Dazu Laura Blecha von der University of Florida:
“Dieses rasante Wachstum der Schwarzen Löcher
vor der Verschmelzung verrät uns, wie wichtig
Galaxienverschmelzungen für die enorme Größe
solcher Schwerkraftgiganten sind”.
Der bisher gängigsten Theorie zufolge findet
vor einer solchen Karambolage tatsächlich
eine Art Todesspirale statt.
Beide zentrale Schwarzen Löcher umkreisen
sich, ihr Abstand zueinander wird dabei immer
kleiner und schließlich kollidieren sie.
Dabei werden Gravitationswellen frei.
Diese hatte Albert Einstein schon im Jahr
1916 postuliert, obwohl er Schwarze Löcher
eigentlich als unmöglich annahm.
Doch bis Gravitationswellen zum ersten Mal
nachgewiesen werden sollten, dauerte es ganze
100 Jahre. 2017 war es endlich soweit: Der
Nobelpreis Physik ging an drei Gravitationswellen-Forscher
aus den USA.
Denn sie hatten jeweils mit ihren Experimenten
und mit ihrer Grundlagenforschung zum ersten
Mal den Nachweis der Gravitationswellen erbringen
können.
Diese werden vor allem von großen Objekten
im All erzeugt, wie eben von Schwarzen Löcher
und Neutronensternen.
Wenn solche Massen schnell genug beschleunigt
werden, wird die Raumzeit so sehr gekrümmt,
dass die Gravitationswellen auch noch in größerer
Entfernung aufzuspüren sind.
Wenn sich die Wellen im Weltall ausbreiten,
wird alles, was sie passieren, in Wellenförmig
gedehnt und zusammengedrückt.
Doch selbst, wenn die Gravitationswellen sehr
stark sind, verformen sie das Weltall nur
minimal.
Der Todestanz der Schwarzen Löcher, bei denen
solche Gravitationswellen entstehen, ist jedenfalls
wirklich spektakulär; konnte bisher aber
nur in einigen wenigen Fällen beobachtet
werden.
Der Grund: Solche supermassereichen Löcher
verstecken sich quasi hinter Wolken aus Staub
und Gas.
So ist es auch heute noch fast unmöglich,
Paare dieser Giganten aufzuspüren und auf
frischer Tat zu ertappen.
Sogar mit sehr leistungsstarken Teleskopen
ist es derzeit noch unmöglich, selbst nahe
gelegene Galaxien gut aufzulösen.
Große Hoffnung liegt deswegen auf der neuen
Generation der Teleskope, beispielsweise auf
dem “European Extremely Large Telescope”
(ELT), über das wir hier bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction auch schon einmal berichtet hatten.
Denn das ELT führt uns in eine neue Ära
der Astronomie und das in gewaltigen Dimensionen.
Das Projekt läuft seit 2012; Ende 2014 wurde
sein Bau genehmigt.
Zehn Jahre später, also 2024, wird das Mega-Teleskop
auf auf einem abgelegenen Berggipfel in Chiles
Atacamawüste dann wohl erstmalig an den Start
gehen.
Und dann könnte es vielleicht tatsächlich
Galaxienkerne, die sich umkreisen, sichtbar
machen.
Übrigens hat solch ein Schicksal an Kollisionen
wohl auch unsere Galaxie, die Milchstraße,
schon mehrmals durchlebt.
Denn auch sie ist bereits öfter mit anderen
Galaxien kollidiert - beispielsweise besonders
heftig vor mehr als zehn Milliarden Jahren.
Offen war bislang, was bei solch einer Karambolage
mit den Schwarzen Löchern in dem Zentrum
der jeweiligen Galaxie passiert.
Bei der Milchstraße gibt es die Vermutung,
dass in ihrem Halo noch Überbleibsel eines
supermassereichen Schwarzen Lochs zu finden
sind.
Und dass diese eben bei früheren Kollisionen
mit Zwerggalaxien entstanden sind.